okay I I think it's time to not
sugarcoat the problem that we may have
called no voter turnout in November and
just kind of tell it like it is I've
been talking about voting in the
midterms we have a lot of different
forms of activism that we are working on
in order to resist the Trump regime but
one of the primary ones that I've been
espousing for a long time is you've got
a vote in November right there's nothing
else if you've been activated by the
election of Trump if you're horrified by
the embarrassment of the United States's
reputation around the world if you're
just concerned about a particular issue
like the possibility as legal analyst
Jeffrey Toobin said of abortion bans in
18 to 20 states over the next couple of
years on the basis of Donald Trump's
soon-to-be announced Supreme Court pick
whatever you're doing in addition to
voting you've got a vote okay and when
we talk about specifically November of
2018 I've told you about the
historically low turnout in midterm
elections that means your vote sort of
matters even more right if the turnout
is expected to be lower on a
mathematical level your vote matters
even more I've talked about the
importance of voting to interrupt the
Trump agenda we've talked about the
Supreme Court implications I've said
before doesn't matter what Robert Mulder
comes up with if you have a Republican
House and Senate between 2018 and 2020
or 19 and 21 as it is effectively you're
not going to have consequences to
Mulder's investigation we've talked
about that as well Pat you've got to
vote for that reason yeah in history
would tell us that the Democrats will do
well in the 2018 midterms but history
also told us that Hillary Clinton would
win the 2016 will actually exactly right
the economy was relatively strong and
Obama was popular but that didn't happen
it did not happen and fortunately in the
middle of 2017 we had high enthusiasm
high engagement in terms of being
engaged and even a few months ago in
April of 2018 several polls still showed
that there was an enthusiasm gap in
favor of Democrats depending on the poll
maybe not quite as big that enthusiasm
gap is rapidly shrinking and potentially
fading and this is a disaster and I have
been doing whatever I can to explain why
you must vote in November
of 2018 I've challenged this false
logically fallacious idea that because
one vote never changes in elections
results it's not worth voting I won't do
that again but I've been talking about
that and I've been explaining why all of
this matters and over the weekend I got
I got an email from longtime viewer
Stephanie who's been a great supporter
of the show by the way for many many
years who said hey David I want to do my
part to get people to vote can I sponsor
some half price memberships for people
who are working on getting people to
vote in November and Stephanie and I
went back and forth and we sort of came
to the reality that in some way it would
have to be on the honor system right
like how can we demonstrate that someone
has earned a half-price membership
there's really no way to do it so here's
what we're going to do okay if you're
doing anything to help take down this
right-wing regime in November you can
get a half-price membership if you want
it Stephanie will pay for half of your
membership memberships are normally 60
bucks for the year all the member
benefits that you get normally 60 bucks
for the year
Stephanie will pay 30 you pay the other
30 just write in and tell me what you're
doing for the midterms if you're phone
banking great if you're helping people
register great if you're just badgering
your friends to vote that's fantastic
and honestly Stephanie even said with
midterm election turnout so low as I
mentioned she said David if people write
in and simply say they're gonna vote in
the midterms and that they want a
half-price membership she's willing to
sponsor that as well so it's on the
honor system if you don't need the
discount and and you would be okay
paying full price don't ask for the
discount the idea is to expand access
and bring more people into what we're
doing for a good cause really a crucial
cause if you want the half-price
membership go to david pakman.com slash
contact tell me what you're doing for
the 2018 midterms and that you want one
of these half-price Stephani memberships
and I'll send you the coupon code it's
the honor system and Stephanie's okay
with that
yeah we're doing everything we can to
get people engaged here yeah our thanks
to Stephanie I love this contest
especially because I think I'm in need
of some hope and yes inspiration and I
think this will provide that to me Pat's
gonna get 1,400 a Half Price
memberships on the basis of I guess his
participation on the show and that that
that's what Pat's piece is half priced
membership just right in david
pakman.com slash contact tell me what
you're doing to help with the November
midterms and I'll send you that coupon
code no limits Stephanie could end up
having to pay for a lot of $30
memberships here because she said she
believes that she can cover as many
memberships as we might get and all
1,400 of mine - that's us she's in for
many many tens of thousands of dollars
on that basis